euh quand ils l'ont confié en le chien à
l'association
la police d'Argenteuil en fait elle
n'avait pas du tout le droit de faire
tout cette porte séjour avant le
jugement et en fait ils ont chauffé
parce que ils pensaient qu'on était
coupable de A à Z et donc ils ont pas
pris le temps de regarder les éléments
ni rien et ils ont confié chiant sauf
que bah là présent il s'avère que bah vu
que j'étais pas le propriétaire de 1 bah
il pouvait pas du coup me le saisir à
moi vu que ce n'est pas le mien et du
coup Roca au mois de juin elle pourra
faire la demande de le récupérer et
surtout aussi on voulait récupérer le
chien moi j'aimerais le récupérer parce
que déjà j'ai enfin
pas du tout je m'en suis toujours bien
occupée et ça m'a fait beaucoup de peine
c'est vrai que la première fois que je
suis venue j'ai pas pu m'exprimer à
cause de du jugement moi je vais passer
en juin faut savoir que je ne vais pas
être je ne vais pas aller au tribunal
par rapport au service gras je vais
aller au tribunal parce que je n'ai soit
disant pas apporté de soins à l'animal
et soi-disant je ne l'ai pas nourri donc
voilà laisser visent grave ont été
totalement sur le dos justement de rap
et m'ont été enlevés et du coup moi en
fait on m'a enlevé mon chien du coup on
m'accuse plus de ces vis et enfin là je
revois des photos ça me touche parce que
bah forcément elle me manquait déjà leur
vue dans cet état ça m'a brisé cœur et
là de voir qu'elle est en bonne santé ça
me fait plaisir mais qu'elle est loin de
moi bah c'est peut-être pour ça
qu'on arrive au jugement nous on propose
justement de payer les soins du chien
parce qu'à ce moment-là ils sont pas en
fait ils ont été faits à moitié
apparemment parce qu'ils avaient pas les
fonds pour faire le reste nous leur dit
mais vous avez les fonds pour nous
envoyer ces avocats mais vous avez pas
les fonds pour payer 800 euros du coup
on propose de payer il nous disent oui
mais ça on voit ça après le jugement et
pourquoi vous l'avez pas proposé avant
et on les a expliqué que on a eu aucun
document on a eu aucune demande de quoi
que ce soit en fait tout a été balayé
pour arriver direct au jugement pour
nous juger parce qu'on était coupable ce
qui vous êtes victime d'une erreur
judiciaire non plutôt par rapport au
commissariat d'Argenteuil qui a très mal
fait l'enquête qui nous a pris nos
téléphones illégalement il y a pas de
télé enfin je veux dire après le
tribunal malheureusement eux ils
récupèrent ce que ce que la gendarmerie
enfin à traiter comme dossier
justement et ça Gilles la première fois
je l'avais dit au journaliste mais en
fait on pouvait pas montrer parce qu'on
n'avait pas le droit en gros à la base
Cyril quand il nous appelle il me dit
ouais avec l'avocate on devait venir
avec l'avocate etc sauf que le jour même
la justice nous appelle et nous dit si
vous montrez une seule des vidéos ou que
vous parlez d'une seule chose qui peut
faire entrave de quelconque manière
enquête on vous allume nous on se dit
mais c'est pas possible ils peuvent pas
faire ça on demande à l'avocate ici
peuvent vraiment faire ça vous-même vous
mettre une peine juste parce que vous
avez dit quelque chose que eux juge
nécessaire et du coup nous on leur avait
tout dit du coup là c'est terminé on
peut tout expliquer enfin alors en fait
comment ça se fait que le chien était
dans cet état c'est ça ça durant leur
explique que nous on est en semaine de
séminaire c'est-à-dire on prépare son
projet parce que Roca n'est pas
influenceuse mais c'est une artiste une
rappeuse et donc on est en train de
préparer le projet requin dit bon on
peut pas garder le chien dans un endroit
où les gens fument etc où il y a de
l'agitation et de la musique super forte
donc on confie en dog sitter donc sitter
un peu stupide qui sait pas qui en fait
chez nous il y a des caméras tout comme
l'influenceuse betka qui n'est pas venu
au jugement ni à la confrontation parce
que ça avait pourquoi et en fait nous on
arrive la police c'est qu'on nous
convoque on dit bah pouvez pas vous
donner les vidéos parce que c'est
Verisure qui gèrent donc on est obligé
de demander à Verisure de vous envoyer
mais nous on aura quand même des doubles
à ce moment-là donc nous on en garde à
vue Verisure on voit tout nous on se dit
bah c'est sûr qu'on va sortir parce que
on savait que c'était le dogiteur qui
faisait les sévices d'ailleurs on
voulait porter plainte on pouvait pas
porter plainte tant que nous nous étions
pas
été persuadé que c'était rose judiciaire
et des personnes extérieures du coup
elle voulait rien entendre rien savoir
avant aucune vidéo aucune version
pourquoi et le Japon le Japon il a pas
le juge d'application des peines non
mais Gilles pourquoi alors pourquoi ils
ont été condamnés
puisque maintenant la justice a en sa
possession
comment vous expliquer
en quoi ils ont fait la technique du 41
7 c'est-à-dire quand il y a 17 en face
d'une seule avocate le jugement au lieu
de durer 30 minutes et qui soit fluide
et que toutes les pros soient étudiées
tous les avocats sont obligés de passer
raconter leur vie pendant une heure et
demie sauf que ce qui s'est passé c'est
que du coup le durement le jugement a
duré 9h et qu'on arrive au moment où la
juge doit analyser les vidéos et cetera
elle nous dit les gars ça devait finir à
13h45 il est 23h et encore 30 personnes
après vous là je peux plus rien faire et
c'est pour ça qu'elle a reporté à un
mois et en fait la police d'Argenteuil
n'a ni les vidéos qu'on l'aura donné ni
les vidéos de Verisure ni les
dépositions parce qu'en gros ils ont
demandé du coup des dépositions de tous
les gens qui ont vu le chien ils ont
même pas une déposition qui était contre
nous là il la prenait et quand c'était
une déposition qui allait dans notre
sens là justement il apprenait pas parce
que ça les intéressait pas dans la rue
vous êtes persuadé que quand vous ferez
appels avec ces nouvelles vidéos que
vous porterez
parce qu'en fait nous on demandait la
relax en fait on était confiant là je
peux le dire parce que la première fois
qu'on est venu on était en colère parce
qu'on pouvait rien dire et en fait mais
les gars elle est sur les réseaux si on
dit pas aux gens où on leur montre pas
un chouia de vérité bah ils vont croire
ce qu'on voit c'est à dire ils sont
coupables ils ont fait si ils ont fait
ça mais là vous êtes en train de dire en
fait qu'il y a un dogiteur donc une
personne qui est payé pour garder les
chiens et bien s'en occuper
non pas peur enfin je sais pas plus ou
pas parce qu'en gros
je vous explique je suis convoqué la
police il me dit c'est qui ce mec j'ai
eu John le numéro l'adresse le truc
d'entreprise ils nous disent on va le
convoquer donc du coup ils appellent le
gars il me disent ouais non non tu dois
venir patati patata le mec il dit non je
viens pas j'ai rien fait mais
techniquement tu as la vidéo tu le vois
bah tu le convoies au moins pour lui
demander sa version des fesses
on voit pas le docteur déjà ça c'est
bizarre ensuite
parce que betka qu'est-ce qui se passe
elle vient chez vous sur le plateau du
coup le jour J et le lendemain il y a la
confrontation donc elle est censée venir
et nous on a la soirée influenceuse
on est ensemble la radio
voilà il on en est où alors moi
j'entends votre défense c'est à dire
qu'en gros vous dites c'est pas nous oui
mais j'ai lu le jugement aussi et le
jugement 2 ans de prison monsieur il dit
c'est vous je vais vous lire quelques
passages ces vis graves et acte de
cruauté privation de soins par blessure
privation de besoin vitaux et
alimentaires et le tribunal souligne la
gravité des faits donc quand même vous
avez été condamné à deux ans de prison
même si vous dites que l'enquête n'a pas
été bonne le tribunal lui il y avait vos
avocats il y avait les avocats des 11
associations qui sont portées participe
vous avez été lourdement condamné je
n'arrive pas à comprendre comment vous
pouvez encore dire que vous n'y êtes
pour rien très franchement en fait en
trois phrases ils ont fait comme j'ai
dit tout à l'heure je rebondis sur
l'actualité ils ont utilisé une
technique qui est de spammer l'audience
c'est-à-dire 15 avocats qui ont à peu
près une heure et demie de temps de
parole sur un jugement pénal qui est
censé durer 30 minutes bah quand ça dure
9 heures bah au bout d'un moment en fait
ce qu'a dit le tout premier avocat au
bout de 9h plus personne s'en rappelle
et c'est à ce jeu là qu'ils ont joué
c'est à dire recal était présente au
jugement par exemple un moment l'un des
avocats il dit que c'était un
influenceur connu avec des millions
d'abonnés qui qui faisait des vidéos de
un message canin mais c'est n'importe
quoi en fait
depuis tout à l'heure mais moi j'ai
l'impression que vous parlez chinois en
fait à un moment c'est le dogiteur à un
moment c'est l'influenceuse à aucun
moment vous prenez vos responsabilités
quand on est maître d'un chien on est
responsable de lui le chien a été
retrouvé son gamelle chez vous donc
quand on a un chien c'est pas juste pour
faire des stories et des clips de Raf
c'est pour s'en occuper donc pourquoi
enfin en fait cette défense n'est pas
clair on a l'impression que vous avez
mis 6 mois à inventer cette défense pour
ne pas être condamné mais aujourd'hui
c'est trop tard non et là tu te trompes
totalement Guillaume parce que ça c'est
la technique des mecs de Twitter
d'essayer de faire ça sauf que non la
réalité c'est que il y a pas une
question de ouais c'est lui c'est pas
lui c'est il y a deux personnes qui ont
agressé notre chien on avait aucune
aucun aucun moyen de faire quoi que ce
soit contre eux c'est passé
deux personnes c'est à dire il y a Momo
qui a déconné et il y a BSK parce que
j'avais pas fini tout à l'heure il y a
eu la peur ce qui s'est passé mais il y
a betka qui a une belle vidéo d'elle qui
met le show dans dans sa veste qui va
dans l'entrée ou pile-point ça pose pas
leur montrer un sonorisé chez nous et
donc il va elle va dans l'entrée à
l'unique et en plus ça devant la caméra
et en fait là où moi je trouve ça drôle
c'est qu'après on voit du coup tout son
manège on voit remettre le chien enlever
les gamelles et c'est totalement faux en
fait vous avez juste à un moment
prodiguer des soins enfin je sais pas
vous retrouverez votre chien après un
dogiteur qui s'en occupe visiblement
comme ça la première chose qu'on fait
déjà c'est on vient d'occitan mais
surtout on va on apporte les soins il
avait des fractures il avait des
blessures
vous êtes en train de parler ce qu'il y
a une gamelle d'eau est-ce qu'il y a pas
de gamelle que le chien il ressemble à
rien soit par pitié mais c'est pas de
reprendre ce chien il a l'air très bien
depuis que vous êtes plus dans son
entourage je suis désolé
[Applaudissements]
et justement ben si tu veux la jouer en
mode de réponse de meuf de Twitter je
réponds comme un mec de Twitter une
fracture et tout ce qui s'est passé ça
s'est passé en une journée